[Music]
I just love that little okay
it is Food Truck Friday this week we are
going Savory pillowy and crescent-shaped
oh what does that remind you of no not
your pillow at home
empanadas oh delicious pastries filled
with a variety of ingredients and they
are super tasty uh John's not here
because he's out there in the parking
lot to meet up with the Empanada Factory
truck for what are they serving up John
well you'll be surprised here Nate
they're actually serving empanadas in
the Empanada Factory uh here we are
inside the food truck which by the way
it's not hot in here at all just for the
record it's nice and cool it's climate
controlled it's wonderful I'm here with
uh with Gabby and Emmy from the Empanada
Factory uh we're cooking up some
empanadas guys thanks for joining us
this morning really appreciate it first
of all just kind of tell us about the
business and how you guys got off the
ground thank you for having us uh well
actually we started two years ago
um having empanadas had a pop-up tent at
a farmer market inside a park and then
we kind of grew up people Embrace
empanadas they love them so we now we
produce a lot of empanadas for music
festivals for uh EDC we go to NASCAR big
places and then we also do deliveries we
do frozen baked and fried empanadas and
what's the uh the appeal of a food truck
why why open a truck and not a
restaurant a brick and mortar store or
some other sort of option uh what is it
what's so cool about food trucks we're
actually
we didn't know it was gonna be this good
so we were like okay let's let's start
small but the fact that you can go
wherever you want to go it's amazing uh
we go everywhere around the city with
the food truck
um and that's good yeah including a
parking lot of a television station
let's come back here let's see what what
Gabby's hooking up here uh we got some
well got some empanadas here that are
frying up got some fries as well uh what
do you got cooking in there well I have
some frying bananas right here I'm gonna
do some hot dog fries and truffle fries
as well and I also have some baked
Empanadas on this side here well this is
the thing about the empanadas we have
around 20 flavors okay uh I had some
vegan I had some dessert empanadas some
barbecue take a look Hawaiian adobo
traditional beef
spinach and cheese
you know we we also have vegan empanadas
as well it's very hard to Stand Here by
the way and have Gabby open the the oven
there and not want to just like try and
take them it's a bit hot in there in
fairness but they're all labeled we
might have a little bit of a taste test
going on uh later on this morning as
well but you're cooking up stuff early
this morning and you guys have just been
slammed with work right yes I hope
you're ready for breakfast uh yeah and I
gave you didn't mention that we're also
working on opening allocation like you
said brick and mortar uh it's not easy
to start you know we started two years
ago after Kobe and Gabby said it's been
really good
and we're ready to give the next step as
well all right well guys thank you very
much for coming in to be here Empanada
Factory uh we'll have some tasting going
on later this morning but for now we're
just going to stay nice and cool here in
the food truck of the Empanada Factory
back to you guys positive thoughts John
I love the way they stamp uh the flavor
of the food on the Empanada 20 flavors
20 flavors including vegan yes we'll
have to try them well it looked like
some had had breakfast eggs and stuff
let's go good stuff awesome let's eat
John we'll be right back